okay we have heard from Harvard Law
Professor Lawrence tribe who is sounding
the alarm that he believes Donald Trump
is not going to leave the presidency
peacefully in 2020 and might
specifically use bogus national
emergency declarations to justify his
re-election as a sort of October
Surprise type of thing so let's step
back before we get into Lawrence tribes
comments and kind of think about the
context for a moment there was
discussion when Barack Obama was
president of Obama declaring Martial Law
to prevent the 2016 election from
happening and to stay in power
indefinitely
there was the idea of Donald of Barack
Obama I don't even know not holding the
2016 election in some other way or using
some kind of arcane legal mechanism to
try to become president for life now it
was ridiculous there was no merit to any
of those accusations Barack Obama had
never said anything of the sort Barack
Obama did not have authoritarian
tendencies under Donald Trump on the
other hand were hearing similar
allegations the difference being that
Trump does have a pattern in history of
those authoritarian tendencies
particularly related to the fairness of
elections Barack Obama never suggested
that president for life would be nice
which is something that Donald Trump has
said Donald Trump has talked about
Hillary Clinton getting three million
illegal votes started a voter integrity
commission election integrity commission
to look into it with no evidence it
found no evidence but Donald Trump was
willing to spend untold amount of money
in order to do that Donald Trump refused
to say that he would accept election
results that showed he lost to Hillary
Clinton in 2016 he has other
authoritarian tendencies that we've
discussed not directly related to
elections we've seen over the last few
weeks some of his flunkies like Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the press secretary
start to float the idea that Trump could
only lose via some kind of voter or
election fraud or foul play in 2020
which is of course an in defeasible
argument you can't
possibly argue against that if someone
is asserting that Michael Cohen said
he's worried that Donald Trump will not
relinquish control of the Oval Office if
indeed he loses in 2020 we've already
done a segment talking about how it's
unlikely in practice that it would
actually be allowed to happen by the
military and by law enforcement but all
of these ideas relate to ways that one
might hypothetically illegally seized
power or refused to relinquish it
Lawrence tribe brings us a different
idea the idea Lawrence tribe presented
on MSNBC over the weekend is that Donald
Trump we know he's willing to file to
declare bogus national emergencies over
things that are not actually emergencies
or crises the situation at the us-mexico
border being our example right now
Donald Trump Lawrence tribe suggests
would use a bogus national emergency
declaration to create a type of fear
that would maybe get him reelected in
November of 2020 that's the idea here is
Harvard Law Professor Lawrence tribe
saying it himself
we can't count on his being voted out of
office in 2020 he is sufficiently
corrupt and will probably have enough
help from not too friendly foreign
powers Russia Saudi Arabia
maybe Turkey so that we can't count on
removing this guy by an election and in
fact he may fabricate yet another
so-called national emergency to
influence that election what we have to
do is persistently gather the facts
right so what he is saying is not that
it would be an illegal seizure of the
White House or a refusal to accept the
results he's saying Trump could use
bogus national emergencies to get
reelected and of course in a country
where half the country doesn't vote half
the population doesn't vote and so many
people are voting based on incorrect
understandings of the world around them
it's not only plausible but it's
extraordinarily feasible to actually do
now any president could do
right any president as their term as
their first term is nearing an end and
with a reelection in doubt could do it
but I believe Pat that it's different
with Trump because he has a history of
having no problem
lying about what even constitutes an
emergency many presidents exaggerates
the seriousness of situations but Donald
Trump has created some of this whole
cloth including with the us-mexico
border and importantly we know that
Trump supporters and his base will 100%
uncritically accept whatever emergency
declaration Trump makes so I think that
this is a more likely scenario that
Lawrence tribe points out not that Trump
will illegally refused to leave the oval
office but that we he will engineer some
kind of false situation to justify his
re-election which will work yeah I think
this is more of an interesting
conversation sometimes we do talk about
if Trump will willingly vacate the Oval
Office if he does lose the election and
I often think that that is putting the
cart before the horse like we have to
find out if he's actually going to lose
the election first we have to have the
election and we should focus on that but
if he prematurely declares the national
emergency knowing that it's going to
garner him some support may put him over
the top that I do think we have to
actually think about it what that
emergency would be on the other hand I
don't know is it's going to be something
more like a false flag or is it going to
be him making a mountain out of a
molehill like we did with this last one
on immigration well the most important
consideration no matter what it would be
is that Trump can't do any of this stuff
without Republican support or at least
Republican indifference because if
Donald Trump does fabricate any kind of
bogus emergency if Republicans don't
allow it right it's not veto-proof if
Trump declares a bogus emergency and the
House and Senate vote it down and Trump
vetoes that vote that veto can be
overridden if and this is the important
if Republicans decide they're not going
to allow Trump to use national
emergencies to try to get himself
reelected at this point the Republican
Party has demonstrated itself to be so
corrupt that they are likely to allow
Donald Trump to do whatever because of
so-called party unity or because a
Democrat would be worth or whatever
species just
they come up with so I think that this
is a much greater danger than the sort
of cartoonish Trump barricades himself
in the Oval Office and refuses to leave
one of today's sponsors is minds.com
mines is an open-source social network
platform it's kind of like YouTube
Facebook and Twitter all in one package
except that the goal of mines is to help
create a free and open Internet where
privacy and free speech are the top
priority and to make sure that content
creators are fairly compensated for
their efforts mines doesn't track you
like a lot of other social networks do
and users on mines can earn mines tokens
for interacting with the site such as
when you like dislike or share content
or when you create content yourself by
uploading a photo or video or writing a
blog post then your minds tokens can be
used to boost your content on the site
so that more people will see it mine's
even offers a feature kind of like
patreon where your fans can unlock your
premium content by sending you minds
tokens everything is encrypted for
example minds can't read your private
messages on the platform and like I
mentioned everything is open source
meaning that in the interest of
transparency you can actually see the
code that fuels the site which is
definitely not something that lots of
other social and content sharing
platforms can say mine's sees a lot of
issues with today's most popular social
media platforms especially when it comes
to free speech privacy transparency and
compensating content creators and those
are the problems that they're trying to
solve I encourage you to go check it out
at minds.com there's also a mobile app
and you can actually follow the david
pakman show on mines at minds.com slash
david pakman show I've also put a link
right underneath this video